so that takes us to our third and what
will be final expedition to the new
world and this is where the spooky part
comes this is where the spooky part
comes in sir walter raleigh and john
white realized that a whole group of
soldiers was probably not the right
group to send to the new world instead
he thinks all right this is what we're
going to do we're going to send
civilians okay we're going to send
families so they send about
90 men
about 20 women and maybe
about 10 children
and
say
okay
you are going to start a colony and a
settlement in the new world so it's not
just a trading post yo but back up like
still on roanoke island next to the
native americans that hate them is that
where they're still putting the colony
well they were really hoping uh since
they've discovered that this is a
terrible place to sail
um that they can actually head up to the
chesapeake bay
and make that their place of operations
why not just make landfall there well
they usually started by going from
england all the way down to bahamas
where they could refuel so this was an
area where they already had power so
instead of going to the unknown land
first they would go down to the west
indies meet up get fresh water get fresh
water and supplies and then come up to
virginia aka north carolina
unfortunately as the weather worked out
they couldn't make it farther than
roanoke island
so
they are hanging out with what they hope
are their friends the sekatans and right
after they get there one of the english
colonists is murdered by probably a
sikatan person and it's because they say
to their translators we
don't have enough food you're gonna
steal more food and we just can't have
you here i mean it's obvious that they
brought women and children they're
intending to stay and
the native americans have decided that
the english are not to be trusted so
this is just like a whole series of
tragic diplomacy by ultimatum movements
right yeah it's really interesting
because i think there are a couple of
places here where things might have gone
very differently you can see the
inflection points if if both sides
decided not to play hardball with each
other so much yeah i think i mean
there's so many places here where you
know ships get lost or they got grounded
on the shoals outside north carolina so
they can't get more supplies or later
you know storms will prevent
reinforcements like weather and a silver
cup are kind of the things that keep
the roanoke colony from succeeding so
right away after this new group of
colonists arrives one of them is
murdered and so they ask their governor
john white to go back to england and get
them more supplies john white the
illustrator who painted
these images on the right and he's now
governor okay uh he's the only one of
the original raleigh's 11 who's still
part of this venture so he's now moved
up in the ranks
so john white sails back to england and
then he runs into a big problem the
spanish basically he wanted to get
supplies some of these colonists
including the dares
are actually john white's children oh
sap so this is his actual family that's
here that he's trying to protect so he
goes back to england and he says sir
walter raleigh i need more
reinforcements but all english shipping
is cut off because of the threat of the
spanish the spanish armada is coming to
england at this time period and so not a
single ship can be spared to go try to
bail out these colonists in the new
world oh wow so they're like alone and
entirely isolated on this new continent
among people that do not like them
because of stuff that people before them
did exactly yeah that's about the size
of it so it's like 1588
when john white sails back to england
and because of the spanish armada it's
not until
1590 that he can finally get back and
try to find these colonists including
his family right when he gets there this
is all he finds the word croatoan
carved into a tree what do you mean all
he thought what what happened to their
town it was completely abandoned
so it looks as if they left of their own
volition because it doesn't look like
there was an attack there and they had
agreed beforehand that if they decided
to go somewhere else remember they
already knew that they were in unwelcome
territory so they thought maybe they'd
go farther inland they would leave
traces they would carve something in a
tree to say where they had gone
unfortunately another storm hit and so
john white was forced to leave and go
back to england without ever going to
see the croatoans this other native
american tribe along with their town
called croatoan to see where the rest of
his family and the rest of the colonists
were did he ever return in his lifetime
no he did not oh that's heartbreaking so
he never found out what happened to his
family and
technically we never found out what
happened to the lost colony at roanoke
but there's some pretty good evidence
about what might have happened to them
tell it to me kim alright so here's what
we think may have happened so there are
about
130 people right right
assuming that none of them died from
disease that's a charitable assumption
yeah
not all of them could have gone to see
and live with the croatoans okay right
because they were a much smaller tribe
than that so they could never have been
all supported by these people what we
think happened is that some of them
went
to
live with the croton so we're along the
coast so if john white comes back
then
they can connect up with him again
so that's what we think happened to some
of them
we also think that some of them went
further inland
to a
more stable environment around what is
maybe called mary hill
so about 15
uh sorry about 50 miles inland from
roanoke island okay today mary hill
north carolina and we think some of them
may have gone north
so here's here's the evidence about
these various things how do we how do we
know that these colonists went there so
when john white was sailing to roanoke
he saw big fires along the coast where
the croatoans lived so we think the
english may have been there trying to
signal them but he went straight to
roanoke and then because of his troubles
with his ship had to go back to england
so there's strong evidence there also
later an englishman heard a legend from
the people who lived in that region that
some of their ancestors had been white
people and they had english coins so i
think it's it's probably safe to say
that some of them did actually
intermarry with croatoans and lived
there for most of the rest of their
lives the ones who went north
we know about because john smith the
captain of the jamestown colony in 1607
met up with some native americans who
told him that there had been white
people living in the area who had lived
peacefully among the native americans
until just recently when they were
massacred by the powhatans powhatan was
the father of pocahontas right so
there's some overlap here so he was
trying to get the lay of the land how
the local people felt about the english
and the intelligence that he got was oh
everyone's cool with the english except
for the people that you're living right
next to
i think it was probably intended yeah to
be maybe a warning
we think what might actually have
happened was that the people from
roanoke had intermarried with another
native american tribe and had become
kind of indistinguishable from them and
then the powhatans who were kind of a
larger empire actually attacked them so
they were killed off in a raid against
other native american groups i see and
the last thing that we think that they
probably went inland uh is from a recent
archaeological dig which has discovered
it's called english border ware okay
in this town near mary hill north
carolina and it was only made in this
time period before these english
colonists left
so we know it has to have dated before
1588. yeah so it's highly likely that at
least some of those people had been
living in this area because we have an
archaeological record of them that's so
cool what i think is really interesting
about this is we actually know a lot
more about this than i think popular
legend says that we do yeah i always
thought that the lost colony at roanoke
was one of those
unsolvable secrets of history i think it
tells us a lot about the historical
process in some ways we know a lot about
this in other ways we don't know much at
all you know there are some things in
history that we don't have records about
and perhaps never will but if i had to
say that there's one thing that's really
haunting about this colony at roanoke is
just how different things might have
been had they chosen to be friendly
about the theft of a silver cup that may
or may not have happened rather than
angry and violent we could be talking
about the colony of roanoke as the very
first successful english colony in the
new world you and i could have been
speaking like an algonquian english
dialect right now quite possibly so it
shows us just how important even the
smallest events in history can be to the
way that things turn out and how much
people's choices really do matter